in other videos we have talked about the
idea that even for a given element you
might have different versions of that
element and we call those different
versions isotopes and each isotope of an
element can have a different atomic mass
and that stems from the idea that if
it's a given element it's going to have
the same number of protons but you could
have a different number of neutrons now
one question that you might have been
asking yourself is how have chemists
been able to figure out what the various
isotopes of an element are and their
relative abundance what percentage of an
element that we find in the universe is
of isotope a versus say isotope B and
the answer to your question is they use
a technique known as mass spectrometry I
can never say it right
mass spectrometry sometimes you'll hear
the word mass spectroscopy and they're
essentially referring to the same idea
and what this technique is is that you
put a little bit of a sample right over
here let's say we're talking about
zirconium in this example and you heat
it up so you have it you have a bunch of
the zirconium floating around and then
you beam it you will bombard it with a
bunch of electrons and what the electron
bombardment does is it can knock off
electrons from the atoms in your sample
and it can I anice them and by ionizing
some of your atoms they now have charge
and because they have charge they can be
accelerated through these electric
plates so now you have these ions in
this case of zirconium moving quite
rapidly through this chamber and then
they enter into a magnetic field and a
magnetic field a strong magnetic field
can bend the path can deflect ions with
charge for a given charge the force of
the deflection will be the same but if
you have a larger mass you're going to
be deflected less and if you have a
lower mass we're going to be deflected
more and so what you see here are the
different isotopes being deflected
different amounts as they go through the
magnetic field and then you have the
detector and at different points of the
detector
you will detect each of these isotopes
and the more ions that hit a certain
part of the detector that means that hey
I have more of that type of isotope in
nature and then from that you can
generate a chart that looks like this
where you see on the horizontal axis
sometimes you will see it labeled atomic
mass and here it's in unified atomic
mass units and you can see when you put
the zirconium through the mass
spectrometer like this you get a little
bit that has a mass number of 96 you
have a little bit more that it's a mass
number of 94 92 91 and most of the
zirconium over 50 percent has a mass
number of 90 now in other cases you
won't see it just in terms of atomic
mass given a unified atomic mass units
sometimes in this horizontal axis
they'll give it in terms of mass to
charge ratio where mass is the mass but
then charge is essentially the charge of
the ions now in a case where your charge
is 1 for example if you knock one
electron off of the atoms and you have a
plus 1 charge well then the mass to
charge ratio would be the same thing as
atomic mass measured in unified atomic
mass units if your ions have a different
charge well then you would have to make
the appropriate adjustment but an
introductory chemistry class most of the
time you will get things in terms of
just straight-up atomic mass if you
happen to get something in terms of mass
to charge just to make sure that if the
charge is say plus 2 that you make the
appropriate adjustment for the masses
but this right over here will tell you
the various isotopes and it will tell
you its abundance and it all comes from
this process of ionizing those atoms
speeding them up deflecting them through
a magnetic field and the ions that have
a higher mass to charge ratio will be
deflected less and the ions that have a
lower mass to charge ratio will be
deflected more and you can use that
information to make a graph like this